well lucas futenbach joins me
now uh lucas everest one of the most
remote places on earth
of course were you surprised to hear
that uh this climber had caught covered
no everyone was aware that this could
happen this season we are running
expedition
during a banana pandemic here so it of
course we were aware that this could
happen
uh we didn't think it would happen that
fast because every foreigner entering
nepal
uh has to be pcr tested before leaving
his home country
then another pcr test enter after
entering nepal
and then in our sense it would be
logical to to test
everyone on the way to base camp that's
what our team does
other teams don't and it seems like
there have been foreigners coming into
the country
without pcr tests and going into the
valley to mount everest without pcr test
and
then it's just just a question of time
so do we know
how this particular climber got
coronavirus
and and how is he now uh he's now
in a hospital in kathmandu and he's he's
good again and he was tested negative
yesterday so
i think he's already released from
hospital um
i have to be honest i have no idea how
how he could get it how he could get
infected but
it's easy on in kathmandu maybe even on
the plane to nepal
when you arrive in nepal you get the pcr
test and it's maybe too early the
testing until
it could be detected and you get tested
negative then you go into the valley
and you develop the infection and of
course this
time of year there are plenty of
climbers all gathering at base camp
because there's a short
weather window and now is the time that
uh climbers want to begin their journey
yes the weather the season for climbing
the mountain is very short it's
basically in
in mid may so now teams are preparing
are stocking their camps preparing
the climbing route uh doing rotations on
the mountain
preparing the bodies for summit push in
mid-may
and yeah all teams are gathering now
in base camp there maybe there are about
something like 1 000 people at the
moment
and there will be more cases i guess
in this season so it sounds like you've
taken sensible procedures but not
everyone will necessarily have done that
and of course rescuing people
from the mountain is very difficult in
high altitude with helicopters
but also i understand that the early
symptoms of covid aren't unlike
altitude sickness yes they can be
pretty similar and one
one way could be to test people to find
out if
the diagnosis what it is uh before
evacuating someone
uh another way could be using an
ultrasound uh device and
and to to find out if it's hey a
beginning form of high altitude sickness
or if it's covet but you're right that
the beginning systems are
pretty much the same and that makes it
very difficult
it does beg the question why are
climbers allowed
to go to everest in the middle of a
pandemic
that's a difficult question and hard to
answer because
uh it has a economical aspect
people here people in the industry
shelbus
are they need expeditions to survive
they need the money that tourists bring
nepal is a very poor country they have
mount everest and they
they need people coming to climb mount
everest they need a
expedition operators to come with their
clients so that's one side the other
side is
uh if everyone would try
to make it to to run the expedition
reliable responsible
trying to keep everything safe to follow
protocols to follow
minimum safety measures it
i think it should be possible to run it
in a responsible way
well we wish you uh and your team uh all
the best and uh and let's hope everyone
keeps uh safe and well
uh lucas thanks for speaking to us thank
you very much